dans plusieurs bars de toronto on peut
maintenant commander un diana ce n'est
pas un nouveau cocktail tendance mais
plutôt un code secret l'employé
appellera alors un taxi ou peut les
aider à quitter par la porte arrière
une façon subtile et efficace de se
défaire d'une rencontre potentiellement
menaçante mais qu'en est-il de celle
initiée à partir de l'application ou
souvent les usagers se donnent rendez
vous à leurs domiciles
la ferme et carter est un rappel sordide
des risques qui y sont associés
le présumé tueur en série avait
plusieurs comptes actifs notamment sur
grindr et sur veude à 10
ces victimes aussi non un juke keynes
mines etc les mécènes dans le village
gai ou ses applications sont extrêmement
populaires ces révélations inquiète un
organisme sans but lucratif propose donc
un système pour rendre ces rendez vous
plus sécuritaire les gens n'ont qu'à une
transmettre leurs coordonnées
ils peuvent ensuite nous écrire avant le
rendez-vous et puis après pour nous
confirmer que tout va bien
ainsi si la personne disparaît
l'organisme peut avertir les autorités
une bonne alternative pour ceux qui
n'ont pas de famille ou d'amis
mais qu'en est il des applications ces
compagnies ont telle la responsabilité
d'assurer la sécurité de leurs
utilisateurs
sept experts croient que oui une
authentification d'une identité avant
une rencontre assez facile et aussi
pourrait diminuer les risques
mais interdire les comptes anonymes
ferait chuter le nombre d'utilisateurs
c'est donc au gouvernement d'imposer des
balises selon lui il y en a des exemples
dans d autres applications donc par
exemple cac ont neuf mètres mis en place
plusieurs protocoles pour ouvrir le
service pour les conducteurs maintenant
ils passent par un entrevue avant qui
peut conduire le monde n'empêche ce qui
est le plus sécuritaire selon la police
de toronto
c'est de se donner rendez
dans un endroit public ici natacha mac
thomas dupuis radio canada toronto